sounds good rez my name is Peter Pan
we're gonna do some more oculus rift
today
last time was absolutely [ __ ]
terrifying without further ado we're
gonna finish this game so it really is a
great difference depending on each game
whether or not I will like it or not
like the immersion some games it just
makes you want to throw up so much and
some games it works completely fine and
I think this is one of those game but it
works fine so we take the elevator down
to the carnival I am a little freaked
out by cloud god what the [ __ ] no [ __ ]
alright um press we survived the first
Oh God what is over outside what the
[ __ ] that's so weird
oh my god m88 I don't get on posters
creepy posters this way for the dingus
clown alright you know what that's okay
and he has blond makeup lights
I hear that spa blur around psychopath
[ __ ] this flame out there ho-jon about
picked up Oh God
and when I like edit my footage on my
app why am I so scared it's not that
scary but when I'm back in in it again
it's [ __ ] horrifying man what's going
on here
hello oh [ __ ]
all right let's go here guess I don't
trust that up not out of place do
something there what did we do that fire
hope they know it's bad for the
environment
Oh God
okay it's just the whole way hold we
can't hurt you unless you get hard to
caddy and I are both F of course I know
detail that way all right
good cuz I was getting lost thank you
sign so much why is it one chapter why
am I doing this I don't get it like I
don't want to potatoes everything okay
this is not that bad this is pretty good
I enjoyed this that said sigh what a
poor sodas machines man good night
hey hey hey what happened it got dark
who likes clowns who brought that idea
the third was a kid I entered like yeah
the kids'll love it
name one child oh god what is the oldest
oh this is making me sick cuz it's like
leaning there we go I feel better now
that's weird
oh god what is this now
save me
[ __ ] safety have you heard of that Oh
God that's not fair this con is an
a-hole this way now what the hell
Oh je pleure okay we're fine no we're
not we're so [ __ ] nedra's oh god what
is all this I'm not your clown
I'm your wait I guess I am you know what
[ __ ] it I'll be the clown I'll beat it
okay what is all this oh [ __ ] what the
what is he doing I don't want to be
chased by him but I feel like I have to
go
oh god it's some giant rat what the hell
it's a horse the [ __ ] horse
what are you stop eating you Sam be
horses man what the hell oh god oh god
oh god oh god okay okay
okay what do you want what do you want
from me you think I'm scared of you you
think I'm scared oh god I'm scared
Oh God okay um uh all right I'm just
gonna power through this [ __ ] Brea's
we're just gonna do it together car is
safe check this way for the Sarkar's
entrance Oh fantastic oh god I hate this
this feels so real man oh god oh god oh
god
motion sickness
oh I made it through without throwing up
yay me what is all this stuff man what
is all this stuff I don't I don't get it
why does he need all this stuff this is
like the lamest circus ever you suck by
the way
seriously though it is pretty lean all
right what else that all is that [ __ ] oh
all right
okay he just laughed at me and you
brought life to you at a whole I'm
kidding it's a Colombian or more blood
and stuff let's keep going because
that's okay with me
oh here's the circus
it just love jumps carry something okay
what is going on
okay go that way what is going on
what Oh God not the carousel how did I
get up here this is not safe
oh god oh god oh no oh God
Oh God okay okay
uh hello we did it I think I deserve a
cookie or some [ __ ]
we actually completed the game holy [ __ ]
it's crazy how games are becoming too
scary now like at the oculus really is
fantastic because it brings me back to
when I started playing horror games and
how I got like scared for the first time
it really brings back that feeling and
that's really like awesome and
terrifying at the same time I don't know
it's really cool and I hope you guys
enjoyed this mini series and my
different hairstyles that came across
with it they like original watching
breath I'll see you in next one love you
say awesome Maha